good morning everyone welcome to Android
developers strike back
last week we heartlessly reviewed camera
apps in the App clinic and redesigned
those apps in Android design in action
now it's time for the developers of
those apps to have their say my name is
reto Meier and I'm bein nee Lewis today
we're lucky to be joined by the
developers of three of the apps that we
looked at last week including IM CTO
ramsey risk glimmer developer paul bork
and alex treason of camera zoom FX as
always we're safe in the Android
developers bunker in an undisclosed
location so Ramsey Paul and Alex are
joining us via Google+ Hangouts
hey guys alright before we meet the
developers let's quickly review last
week's prescriptions rate Oh what makes
a great camera it's a very visual medium
so you want everything to just work so
in first and foremost you want it to
look great without contradicting the
design guide and I think that was
something that we really wanted to
emphasize because cameras are an
artistic medium they deserve an artistic
user interface they don't need to look
like an alarm clock or a text editor but
they need to not contradict or change
our design guidelines in a way that
might confuse users we want to make sure
that it supports every image is an image
gallery so there's a lot of these apps
which providing filters photos we want
to make sure that it works even if
Picasa or some other image provider
Flickr or whatever yeah exactly we
mentioned you know some way to be able
to browse a community of photography
which I think really helps draw you in
yeah there was something that I hadn't
really thought about but it is a really
nice bonus to help you feel like you're
part of a larger community and compare
your photos with others without cameras
so Nexus 7 devices anything like that
which may not have a back facing camera
but it's a really great device for
looking at photos and enjoying that
community now remember though we ended
up adding one thing at the end though we
didn't put on this slide and that is
that at least as of jelly bean which is
much faster OS UI wise than previous
os's
from Android you should be able to have
jank-free scrolling in your app so as
I'm browsing large number of images now
of course sometimes you're gonna see a
blank or placeholder image as that image
comes down from the network but if the
images have been loaded you should be
able to scroll up and down without
seeing any jjang by jank we mean just to
framerate drops you know little pauses
in the in the scrolling if some of the
apps did that really really well better
than our own apps in fact pretty much we
look at in the future I think that's
gonna be a big part of it absolutely so
let's get started then let's have a look
at each of the apps so these are the
apps that we reviewed on Friday that's
how I meet glimmer cameras in effects
and I think I think she said I need
again but it's really I am I am I don't
know why I keep saying I me oMG Stevie's
willing to change the name it's gonna
make it much easier for me yeah so
happily we do have the developers of
three of these apps to speak to today
we're gonna start with with randy from
IM and so before we before we do kick
over to him i just want to show you
quickly on screen here what the what the
lab results were judging by the criteria
which we put forward and i think the two
big concerns we had were the ability to
support every image in the gallery and i
think we had a couple of concerns about
the design guide and can you remember
what was the jack factor like on
I am I'm sorry I don't I think I think
it was reasonable standoff let's get
Renzi on and and let him speak for
himself
higher higher on Z can you uh spend a
little bit of time tell us a little bit
about yourself a little bit about the
app just so the audience knows who you
are
absolutely first of all thanks for
having us and thanks for the review we
can rename it to I me as soon as you
guys release you know support for action
bar yes or is there
yeah so I'm Ramsey I'm one of the
engineers behind I am and one of the one
of the four guys that founded it
originally not much to say about myself
I I develop Android among other things
I've recently I think we have some our
team has grown over the last few months
and now we have actually some really
awesome developers that are taking care
of most of the Android development
that's why the app has gotten so much
better over the last uh four months but
yeah and and and I am itself is well you
can say it's a photo sharing platform
but we like to think of it as the next
generation of photo discovery so you
know photo filters hipster photo filters
are all awesome but what we really like
our data filters and what we think is
that the fact that you're taking photo
with your mobile means you can you have
so much more information available to
you that you don't need to make the user
enter so you don't need the hashtags you
don't need all of that but cancer
education information you know what sort
of location it is and based on that you
can always learn a little more and make
better recommendations and that's what
we're trying to do with with I am so the
idea is whenever you take the photo
you're telling us a little bit more
about what you like and how you live and
we use that learn a little more I've
make always better recommendations so
that you're always getting nicer content
recommended to you are you're always
discovering content sort of independent
of the social graph so it's you know
buzzwords tropical graph is interest
graph all of that and that's what we're
focusing on very nice and that's in fact
I think the the key thing for me when I
was browsing
the app was being able to sort of follow
these little breadcrumbs of links you
know think so that's taken in at the
Android building I would love to see how
many other photos there are so that you
know for me was really compelling
absolutely the dryer is very interesting
service and well it's can I say one more
thing well first of all I again I want
to apologize because the app crashed
while you were demoing it while you're
trying to take a photo and I mean this
is a funny story cuz we'd actually just
released that update a couple of hours
before the show and we've switched we've
switched our location detection stuff
into the representation that you have on
Google Groups the protips
location yes or so we're sort of
inspired by that and we tested and it
was all okay except in the case of
latitudes that were minus 120 2122 so
basically yeah and thanks for reporting
it because I would otherwise wouldn't
have found that that's great that's
really interesting so Romans just
playing with yeah sorry he's playing
with the app right now it may also be
like how Googleplex is a tech startup
near you yeah that's how we roll
absolutely so yeah I think you know the
scrolling is definitely usable but as
you said it wasn't the standout there
are apps that scroll a lot better than
this but in general the performance is
pretty good and I really really like the
way that you can see these different
categories although some of them are a
little bit mystifying like I don't know
why that pretty girl on the train tracks
was labeled coffee maybe that's some
sort of slang I think that's the main
objection that we had to the UI was the
camera button what do you think I
absolutely agree I mean it's you guys
definitely know this I mean it's a bit
of a challenge trying to keep up with
what design guidelines in a lot of ways
and especially like you said when it
comes to photography apps you have to
have like your own spirit and we're very
design driven company
so now the team of people that are
always tweaking this stuff and actually
this is about things that they're
looking at so they start basically
looking and realized that issue when you
mentioned it last Friday it was it and
they're looking they're looking at ways
to improve that so I definitely will be
able to make sense it's certainly tricky
when you have capacitive buttons I mean
that's you know different manufacturers
do different things and of course a lot
of manufacturers do have big fixed
buttons but they're all getting sued so
apparently that's no what can I welcome
right and I do notice that this app it
doesn't sort of point you towards the
camera in that it it has the sort of
bubbles which float around the the
button to indicate hey something's down
here and you should check it out I
wonder that's that's that's when it's
loading more content that's off the
loader your spinner that's interesting
okay that's kind of cool
Roman I know you spent a bit of time
looking at different camera apps and
they're all gonna have this same sort of
issue as to how do you make the button
more you know visible do you have any
sort of tips for iron in particular yeah
well I mean I think the the one problem
I have with the placement is that the
the other half of the button it's
negative space basically it's like me
you almost see the other half of the
button overlapping with the home button
so when your your finger just jumps to
that location your finger jumps to where
the home button is I think in you know
the the general location it's kind of
hard to move it to a completely
different part of the screen but you
know having it you know fully on the
screen or just bigger making it a larger
touch target it's gonna drastically
minimize the number of errors but yeah
it is just you know something that's
difficult especially for camera apps
where that is probably the most common
place for a shudder fair enough that's
that's fair I mean I said the other
let's see you know otherwise I think oh
there was the the menu button yeah where
I'm see help us out you gonna get rid of
the menu button man
and actually like the stuff that you
mentioned it's it's all being taken care
of we're finally you know doing final
testing for supporting well going up to
target SDK 16 and we've dropped the
camera required made it into or you know
camera versions now required fall so
basically you can use it with or without
and whilst it you mentioned that we took
care of gallery stuff yeah sorry
being able to edit images for yourself
from Picasa or Flickr or wherever else
that's all that's all in there that's
should be hopefully out there tomorrow
night
that's and yeah and I'm scrolling I
think we might have nailed the the jank
eNOS part is a big challenge it is
really hard isn't it
it's um when you're dealing with this
much information and these bitmaps are
large enough that any one of them could
just about blow your Java heap we've
actually I spent a long time here just
trying to figure out all of the best
techniques for that dan galpin has been
working on it I mean in his spare time
which sauce right but yeah I will say
that at least on this build the jain
keenest does seem to be increasing a
little bit making me think that there is
a memory leak somewhere some kind of
resource leak but yeah the problem
exactly it's we do cache images so they
have to layer 2 2 layer caching yeah and
the disk caching it sees that in this
caching is causing some of these issues
as well as so the seek time on disk
which is what we're trying to figure out
right now and finalize okay yeah we'll
definitely be keeping an eye out for
that it sounds like you've pretty much
already done all the things that we we
thought needed to be doing so I'm right
you know we're we're still looking for a
pure Java solution but I think that for
some photo things you actually do have
to drop down into the Linux layer and an
NDK because at that point you can do
efficient file mapping and you can do
decoding with neon instructions instead
of with Java instructions so that that
may be part of it there's also one one
thing that you have to avoid like the
plague is allocations during your
scrolling because as you
as you acquire and release objects you
know every release as a possible GC yeah
um so yeah well I mean we definitely
love to hear from from you and from your
team once you guys have the next launch
out and if it is nice and smooth it
would be you know great to hear some of
the hints that you guys might have for
other developers which are gonna be in
countering the same thing I some of our
other guests may may have some awesome
advice as well now let's uh let's go
ahead and take a look at Romans redesign
uh you have one for that I think we did
for I am I think I think Roman left that
one alone I think glimmer and cameras
are good the way it was I think so
except for that camera button for the
camera hood Roman did you you didn't
feel like you wanted to spend half an
hour just you know talking about
different ways to put a camera button on
screen yeah I think the thing is what we
try to do with with Android design in
action is we try to look at that apps
that you know have a lot of you know UX
possibilities like a lot of you know
something that we can change drastically
and still maintain the core I think I am
pronouncing that right I think I am just
like you guys are very close the
redesign that the only reasons we would
do it probably be just very small visual
tweaks here and there so we don't think
it was kind of worth spending too much
time on it yeah I think really the main
critique that I have of the interface is
that compared to some of the other photo
apps we saw it takes a long time to get
a full sized image and once I've drilled
down into the full size then you can't
just move to another image really
quickly so yeah write it like I in
general and maybe rounds maybe you could
put Ramsey back up down I think um you
know what I'm looking at this interface
I feel like it's got everything that I
want but it's not ordered in the order
that I want it most so the frequency of
wanting to go from picture to picture
with some of this information is much
lower than
wanting to actually interact with some
of this extra information like once I
have I wish I could just go immediately
to this screen and then swipe back and
forth of pictures so back and forth of
pictures and then up and down for other
things in the category or maybe even a
like a drawer or something because
remember that photo apps are all about
browsing photos right cool
well I think that's all the time we've
got to spend on I am so thank you very
much for joining us today and thank you
for a great app we're really looking
forward to seeing the update and you
know getting all of the extra stuff that
we asked for so yeah absolutely thanks
man thank you guys thanks very much for
joining us all right so next up we're
gonna take a look at glimmer by our poll
book so this was this is a little bit
different from some of the other apps
that we looked at in that it's not about
taking photos it is about browsing
Flickr effectively so it's it's very
much here it's all about being able to
create these rich smooth scrolling
experiences so we gave him a couple of
red marks but it was some stuff which
the app doesn't actually have to do so
but let's say let's go over once you
introduce yourself Paul so Paul is
actually having some trouble rejoining
our hangout maybe we can move on to the
next app and get the next developer on
back Paul yeah we can totally do that
let's say let's move on to camera zoom
effects while while we're waiting for
Paul to get his hangout connection
working once again so this is a little
bit more like I am in that it is
effectively a camera replacement I think
the the key difference here was that
camera zoom effects wasn't so much about
the community of photography it was more
about being able to create great photos
with an app that replaces the native
camera or at least that was my
perspective so it'll be interesting to
hear Alexes I think where we gave it a
red mark here again was the community
stuff and some issues with the design
guide and this is in fact an app which
Roman and his team took a look at so I
think we'll actually start by having a
quick look at some of those changes so
Roman if you want to talk us through
we've just got basically the two
screenshots on screen do you want to
give us a very quick rundown on
you know some of the thinking behind the
changes that you did and we can let Alex
tell us why they are not a good idea
yeah so like we said an Android design
in action I think the main thing that we
wanted to do is from an interaction
standpoint just simplify the location of
things so we basically put the camera in
settings and the right and then effects
which is I think the most awesome part
of this app so many awesome effects we
put that on the left just to simplify
the model for users and then we started
grouping things like the the shutter
time or the shutter type and the camera
settings we moved that along with other
settings into a single screen and then
we made the image the entire camera
preview take up the entire screen which
I think can be it is not possible in
some cases but that's it was the entire
screen and all the controls are just
overlaid the last point I wanted to make
was that we branded just shutter the
shutter button itself and we made it so
that it was larger and kind of further
away if possible from the home button to
I'm trying to minimize the or the number
of so I think those are the main thing
alright perfect so let's see if we can
get we can get Alex on screen and just
tell us so again tell us a little bit
about yourself Alex and about the app
and and then we can start talking about
some of the changes which which roman
his team suggested and how they fit into
your vision of the app going forward
sure yeah my name's Alex Drazen I've
been working with Android now for about
three three or so years camera zoom FX
was one about first hour and I could
weigh of where we've kind of been quite
fortunate is to be involved with Android
you know right right from the beginning
and I think cameras iam effects was
actually the first app on the Google
Play or Android Market as was then to
support digital zoom so yes if starting
out we were trying to solve a lot of the
I supposed to be in built problems
you're going back to the days of the g1
and you know 1.5 1.6
so yeah kind of built from there digital
zoom was was kind of what started it
hence the name
and we originally can resume that Megan
we edit the air first change the name to
can receive it I see what you did there
yep it's getting longer and longer I
don't think we'll change the name again
but but yeah I mean essentially that
there are kind of too hard to the apps
there as you mentioned that the first
half is is at the capture time trying to
kind of improve on the ability that
people have what they're composing and
taking pictures so we're looking at
things like a grid compositions stable
indicators smooth
time-lapse but to make for example we
can take up to 10 10 shots per second
and I guess kind of where we're going is
we look at doing a major update every
year we did a major update last last
August and I see my cat that kids just
just come into the frame well it
wouldn't be a hangout with that a cat
well absolutely and and and this year we
actually have another big update which
is coming out probably in the next few
weeks actually so I'd like to say thanks
to to Redmond and to Nick for looking at
the redesign actually because it's um
it's very good timing for us we haven't
finalized the design so what you've
given us is the chance to kind of see
you know what we've got what's working
and where we can improve so you know a
lot of points that you raised we you
know we completely agree with it so you
know starting with things like the
shutter button we have had a lot of
feedback around that you know we are
bigger we actually love Romans design
you know with the will you know the
context around that we think that looks
really great
we'd like the fact that it's bigger it's
further away from the home button we
also agree probably the most useful
settings and yet are kind of the power
features that you like so the changing
the autofocus mode so we kind of agree
with with Romans points there about
giving that to the right-hand side of
the screen I supposed to be the only
issue that we have is that because the
app is kind of in two halves we have the
you know the capture time and the FX
screens what actually happens once you
kind of flip to the FX mode
the effects becomes a kind of most
important toolbar what we try to do is
have a kind of a similar interface at
the capture time as you would have at
the FX time so that's kind of one one of
the reasons why FX has ended up on the
Reiko we are kind of reviewing that to
see if there is you know possibly
another another approach we can take
yeah I I can't remember exactly what
Roman did with this but I remember when
we reviewed it we said would be actually
interesting to put this on a viewpager
so I can go back back and forth between
camera and effects or have some other
way you want to keep the the interface
sort of similar in that once you learn
it in one mode you don't want to have
been a completely different experience
when you switch to the other mode yeah
so all right well so here's a beautiful
photo that I just took very nice
yeah Rito making kissy faces at Dan
so yeah we what Roman what what all is
wrong with this interface or could be
changed it could be better or Paul with
this is Paul right no this is Alex I'm
Alex yeah Alex do you want to weigh in
on on what you're changing here yeah
we've actually got a whole bunch of
changes coming down the line we're
actually moving up conversion 3.5 which
is on the google play now up to version
4 so it is a major update I mean some of
the features that are going in there
auto-rotate man it's something that you
mentioned on the day yeah absolutely
agree that that needs to be and there's
actually quite a bit of work because
there's so many controls on the camera
screen and we actually have to in terms
of the actual it's a landscape screen
being had to possess some controls kind
of turn on the side so that has created
work for us but we were pretty confident
we're kind of happy with the way that's
gone that's great
we also following on from your feedback
you talked about being able to work on
devices with you know front-facing
camera only or devices that have no
camera and that's something that will be
fully supported we'll keep doing more on
the holo theme so
again Romans work you know we loved it I
showed it to my designer and he's kind
of yeah bless that's kind of you know
that's kind of do what my designers done
and this kind of deal with Romans up
romans done and kind of put the two
together and we can you know something
really good this is such a treat so we
review these apps and then within a
couple of weeks we're gonna have new
versions of all of them with all of the
features we asked for we should review
more apps that's great nice yeah I kind
of almost feel like there's not much
left to ask cuz we can just look in a
couple of weeks and see exactly what
that does I'm really curious to know
what sort of eye problems you had or
what what's her challenges you need to
overcome developing this app for Android
obviously it does a lot of very
complicated work yeah I guess you know
because we kind of with that from the
beginning we were always trying to
support right back to you know Android
1.5 and when you look at cameras you
have so much the main complexity is in
the camera screen not in the FX screen
so I am on the camera side of things
it's really just trying to pull together
a consistent app which can deal with
everyone has different you know focus
modes different scene modes different
filters available the zoom works
differently on different phones we
actually managed to even provide zoom on
focus like it was the Nexus S which you
know didn't support any kind of aim at
all
it really has just been a case of just
carrying them I mean I have hope I have
eight eight devices myself and we have
deserts all around the world who are
giving us feedback and saying you know
what works you know one of my test
devices is not not necessarily gonna
work somewhere else yeah so you know the
real complex complexity is is to do with
the fragmentation but it's also you know
it's been a real opportunity because you
know we're now in a position where we
have over a million users you know all
around the world and you know we're
getting this amazing feedback you know
through from all different places so
it's an opportunity but it's it's an
ongoing challenge
and every type of major new device comes
out you know like the Nexus 7 before
that you know the Galaxy Nexus we were
always facing problems and on indicate
one of the runs that we have is that we
get the devices are to you point after
users will find problems before we even
have a chance to fix them so it's an
ongoing battle but but you know we're
really happy where we've got to I think
I think this particular release we're
focusing a lot under design and adding
some additional camera features so for
example things like brightness exposure
controls closer controls which again
vary quite a bit between devices
pinch-to-zoom we think we've got that
working now in a way which won't affect
the you know the older devices so you
know we can calculate the way it's
looking we're going out to visa next
week so you know we anyone who wants to
kind of take part in that just just you
need some takers yeah yeah so one of the
things that it's one we're kind of
running out of time a little bit but I
did want to dig a little bit deeper into
what you talked about having testers all
over the world so you know I think with
a camera replacement app as you say you
know you're going to be right on the
forefront of really having to test on a
lot of different hardware because there
are just a lot of different cameras so
are those people who work as part of
your organization or do you have sort of
a public alpha testing group of people
who you send out you know to test the
app on a lot of different hardware we
have a group who you know every time we
go to beta they big they pretty much you
know there are our core group of testers
and that's going to be sort of between
10 and 15 and then in addition to that
what we do is you know once you know
once we are at this stage where we're
ready to go to visa we do invite people
we know through channels such as this or
or you know when people email our
support desk you know we're kind of -
actually the feature you're requesting
that's something we've worked on them
you know would you be interested in
seeing the beta for that feature and
nine-time nine times
they're gonna say yes send this me
straightaway and you know if someone's
emailed you recently you know that they
have an active interest in your rack the
fact that they're talking to you know
that they're going to spend the time
looking at it getting valuable feedback
so to be honest it's never been a
problem getting testers that's never
been a problem until yes it's kind of I
suppose having enough time to kind of
spend on each case I suppose it's
probably more challenging sure I can see
how that would work I mean it's as a
user I mean that's what you really want
is like you email the developer and go
yeah this thing isn't working on my
phone or I want this feature and to get
that email back going yeah actually we
fix that do you want to be to test it
it's kind of an awesome experience I
mean maybe it's because we're geeks but
you know it's it certainly tells me that
the developer cares about the app and
cares about the community people using
well and I think as a developer feeling
like you've got a community behind you
it's got him that's got to be a great
feeling
so Bravo we are just about out of time I
was was Paul able to get in well Paul
was able to join the hangout I think
okay I think he was joining us via a
device rather than a computer which is
uh it's it's impressive that it can be
done it's unfortunate that it didn't
work out but we'll try and get some
feedback from Paul and maybe share it on
G+ afterwards I think it would have been
really useful to talk to folks I think
glimmer was the app which had the
incredibly smooth scroll you know this
is exactly what happened right we said
oh maybe some people will give us some
hints about smooth scrolling boom Paul's
gone and he's giving it that I didn't
realize that was this kind of show yeah
yeah he's going yeah you're cutting off
I'm going through a tunnel alright
alright
let's go ahead and wrap up the legs very
much Alex thank you Ramsey and thanks in
absentia Paul absolutely yeah thank you
all for joining us it's it's really
great to hear back from you developers
you know to find out a lot about what
the challenges are how you've overcome
and in this instance especially to find
out all of the cool stuff that you've
already done and we'll get to look at
very serious yeah we really appreciate
everyone who is taking the time to
listen to what we have to say and
implement
design guidelines and Android features
that you didn't have before that's
always not only a great way to satisfy
your users but a great way to get the
Android development community to look at
your app and possibly even promote it on
Google Play
absolutely so we'll certainly be looking
out for these updates because we want to
nominate those for featuring on Google
Play we don't have very much power in
that sense but we can always only try
send an email absolutely absolutely and
I think these apps are good enough that
it's gonna be so I think they're
fantastic amount of someone and I think
they'll say the the benefits right away
also coming up later this week so on
Friday Meany ain't gonna be back for the
app clinic to get the the apps which
we're gonna then I talk about next week
in this show so this week we're going to
be looking at travel planning and
booking apps yes we're gonna go back to
our desks after this and choose the apps
to look at so if you haven't already
nominated your favorite travel booking
and/or planning app do run onto the
moderator page and now you can find that
at developers.google.com slash live
slash android navigate your way to the
app clinic show that is Friday and the
moderator page will be right there
absolutely and in what will probably
turn out to be a fruitless attempt to be
more prepared we are also going to
choose the apps for next week tomorrow
so that we'll have a week to look at
them so if you have any specific ideas
for I'm sorry what was the I have no
idea what a look at our moderator and
find out what we decided next week is
going to be in taked indeed who are you
saying about being prepared that we were
gonna try and do it and fail miserably
so in terms of that went well did a
couple minutes if they were correct I'm
happy that we went that far at least and
then of course we've got the game's
review with with Dan and
don't know who's gonna be with den and I
don't think we shall to know what the
the entire game show tomorrow is gonna
be a potluck - a dandy
well that's something to look forward to
absolutely um so yeah that's it that's
it for us thank you again thank you to
our developers for joining us and to
Daniel for engineering the show and for
to Roman for joining us all the way from
New York where it's late in the
afternoon by now and I'm surprised he
hasn't already gone home
my name is Ryder I'm Ian and thank you
again for joining us see you later right
but